hello everybody very good morning to you
it is seven o'clock and you are very
welcome to join us here on the breakfast
show on sky news wherever you're
watching us around the world this
morning some shock breaking news to
bring you from overnight in the us on
abortion laws and something hillary
clinton has called an utter disgrace
we'll get the reaction of the
international trade secretary and
maurita rebellion we'll also get her
take on the high number of bank holiday
channel crossings and ask is a plan to
send asylum seekers to rwanda
really putting people off the shadow
international trade secretary nick
thomas simons also on the show some
uncomfortable headlines about his leader
this morning it is tuesday the 3rd of
may
our deepest fears coming true protests
after a leaked document
indicates the us supreme court has
provisionally voted to overturn the
ruling legalizing abortion
ukraine's finest hour boris johnson will
become the first world leader to address
kiev's parliament as russian attacks
continue
evacuation efforts stall in mariopol as
russia again starts shelling the city's
besieged steelworks
royal security breach a report about an
intruder pretending to be a priest who
spent the night with the queen's
guardsmen
our need for the truth 15 years since
her disappearance madeleine mccann's
parents speak out
that's as the man suspected of abducting
her claims he has an alibi i'll reveal
details this hour
delays and danger areas as millions
prepare for their summer holidays we'll
take you through the passport pitfalls
that could hold you back that's at half
past eight
birthday
mr president
happy birthday
to you
and remember that dress kim kardashian
steals the show at the met gala in a gun
worn by marilyn monroe
also coming up on the programme for you
this morning with the hrt medication
shortage still causing problems for
thousands of women will speak to a
businesswoman forced to go without after
hunting in seven separate pharmacies
we're all familiar with the dangers of
speed but what about problems that
relate to noise pollution
and silencing rowdy drivers will speak
to former racing driver amanda stratton
about a new campaign to banish boy and
girl racers
[Music]
morning we begin with some breaking news
overnight from the u.s on abortion laws
hillary clinton has called it an utter
disgrace protesters have taken to the
streets outside the supreme court saying
their deepest fears are coming true the
news that's triggered this backlash
leaked document that indicates a
majority of u.s supreme court justices
plan to support overturning a historic
law that legalized abortion
i absolutely have to be out here because
this is something that
affects me so personally and and hurts
so much to know that has
might be ripped away from me
the unborn are human and we've been
killing them in mass to the tune of
millions
and so
this
i have no words i have no words
on our us correspondent greg milam is
standing by for us this morning hello to
you greg very good morning good evening
where you are um how has this come about
and when will we know what the plan is
well if the final ruling from the
supreme court which we expect in the
next couple of months is in line with
this draft ruling it will be hugely
significant for the u.s it will
immediately ban abortion in a number of
states others will follow pretty quickly
as well
it is unprecedented to get any sort of
leak out of the supreme court it's a
very secretive organization um so the a
leak of a story of this significance is
astonishing really it's a draft ruling
written by samuel alito who's one of the
the more conservative supreme court
justices it was written in february it
could have been amended since then but
in it he says that the supreme court
shouldn't just side with the states who
want to restrict or ban abortion but
they should go further and they should
overturn a thing called roe v wade now
that's a ruling from 1973 that
guaranteed a constitutional right to
seek an abortion uh the court has been
deliberating on this since uh december
uh they're due to rule in the next few
weeks hugely consequential uh ruling and
the question always be wars was how far
would they go would they overturn roe v
wade because the court is very
conservative at the moment now the
impact would be that it would ban that
in in 12 states almost immediately and
many more would follow a huge anger
particularly from democrats okay for now
thanks craig joining us now is the
international trade secretary and marie
trevelyan good morning to you thanks for
joining us on the program i wonder if i
could get your reaction to that to start
with please um hillary clinton has said
if true it's an utter disgrace what do
you think well as ever with leaked
documents uh you never quite know so
let's wait and see but i'm certainly a
woman who believes uh in choice for
women
and when the roe versus wade ruling came
through decades ago now it's sort of
before you're in my time you know it's
sort of part of part of our history that
uh that acceptance that actually women
should uh have control of their bodies
uh was something that set a standard for
the rest of the world uh and allowed
women uh to be empowered uh in uh this
very very critical way so uh we'll wait
and see clearly it's uh uh whether this
is a true document or not but i think
there will be a great deal of anxiety uh
if that seems to be true and i i suppose
if it goes to a back to a state by state
level uh the us will uh have to deal
with that uh in a different way but
we'll all have to wait and see of course
what support or pressure
could or should the british government
try to put on the u.s government so
these sorts of laws are you know
national decisions and governments uh
you know need to take decisions they
have uh elected representatives through
which they
share their views and uh in america like
in many democratic countries uh the
voice of the people is often heard and
uh their campaigning uh is usually uh
you know taken through so i imagine if
there's if this were to come uh to be a
change in in a very long-standing law
that there would be very strong uh
campaigning from uh citizens from across
the u.s now i know that you've been
talking trade haven't you with in your
in your role as international trade
secretary with the u.s just last week
would that potentially be an opportunity
in future for us to express a uk view on
this sort of thing so we don't use our
trade tools which are about you know
buying and selling goods and services
and working together to
improve routes of trail things like
through digital trade um we don't bring
in but the you know the fcdo our foreign
office uh uh speaks on all matters what
you might call diplomatic i think which
is what you refer to in those those
continue all the time regardless of our
trading relationship our trade
relationship with the u.s is incredibly
strong and long-standing uh and that
will continue to be so but i uh on all
matters uh when there are matters of
concern uh then the foreign office would
be the department that would
mention it in diplomatic channels
uh so uh not being in the foreign office
uh i don't know but i think could raise
issues of concern are always raised to
diplomatic channels whatever they might
be they're done privately often because
that can be a most effective way uh of
you know setting out the view but this
is a matter of concern i think it's what
i'm trying well i think it's a matter of
of great concern i think to to all women
uh in the us if this is a rowing back on
a you know 50-year
50-year state of state of of things but
uh we'll have to wait and see whether
it's true or not okay uh we um we've
done a deal not a not a trade deal but
we're going to deal with rwanda as we
know we saw the uh home secretary over
there just a couple of weeks ago um the
ruling to send migrants who come across
the channel to rwanda became law last
thursday when when are we going to send
our first migrants to rwanda
so as you say the law has uh now been uh
brought in as an act at the end of uh
the parliamentary session uh so the uh
rwanda policy will now start to be uh
brought into place i don't have a
precise date for the case i can't i
can't tell you that but i know that the
uh home secretary and the team are
working very closely to set this place
one of the things about was it was to be
able to look back since the beginning of
the year so uh those who are being
fooled and put put their lives at risk
uh because of the uh people smugglers
who are uh bringing them across in those
schools just deterred people is the
point i'm trying to make 550 migrants
came across the channel can any of those
that came over the weekend expect to
find themselves in rwanda so i can't
answer that question okay because i
don't know who they are but the point of
the pro policy is to make sure that we
uh try and really discourage this
activity because it puts people as it's
the busiest stretch of water the channel
incredibly dangerous place to be and we
want to make sure
that there are many many legal uh
migration applications
yeah you acknowledge that it's not been
a deterrent yet has it well it's only
literally just coming into place so uh
you know like all things it takes a
little while to actually get all the
processes and i was asking when so and i
don't and i don't have an answer for you
in terms of uh precise dates but uh the
policy has been set out and the home
office are working at pace to bring that
into action because we do not want
people to put their lives at risk being
uh conned by people smugglers to take uh
take themselves to the scene so we'll
find out in the fullness of time um big
day day after tomorrow local elections
what would you view as a success
so it's a funny set of elections because
it's uh not across the country it's not
all uh councils i was uh supporting uh
some young candidates yesterday uh where
uh some of them are up for election uh
and many of them aren't because that's
how our election system works so i think
there are some places where uh there's
some there's some you know close fights
but i think also in many places
certainly on doors i've been knocking on
there's been a continuing sport that has
a local level because of course these
are all local elections they're at your
council uh people who have got
conservative councils know that they've
got uh you know uh great local services
four times as many potholes filled in in
conservative councils as labor i won't
talk about potholes what i'm talking to
you about what would you view as a
success so i think uh you know as ever
with local councils elections uh will
win some will lose some uh that's that's
the nature of the beast anyway uh but
also that you know twelve years
and fifty seats so i'm not uh close to
the precise detail but i would expect us
to win someone new some that would be
normally expected but what i think we
will see uh is a really strong showing
by conservative voters who want to come
out and demonstrate they know that
locally run councils run by and
conservatives are better sure and no
matter how poorly or well how poorly
let's say the conservative party does
the prime minister will remain in post
you won't see this as a referendum on
the prime minister no why not
uh because as i say local council
elections in these strangers are not a a
they're not a broad reflection of the
whole you don't get a picture of the
vehicles they're a protest vote a bit
like a by-election well sometimes you
get that but as i say you wouldn't be
able to see that in the whole because
they aren't all out elections in most
places uh but you know as i say 12 years
into government you do get as you
describe it sometimes a protest vote and
you know that's the beauty of democracy
that's one of the reasons we're
supporting
ukraine as they fight to maintain their
democratic right to be a free nation
yeah and is that something that the
party is preparing for potential protest
vote against the prime minister
uh no not the prime minister is getting
on with the job of uh delivering uh a
whole series of policies to make our
country uh you know move forward in many
ways
from uh you know more hospitals and more
schools supporting
our police and nhs by bringing in
more amazing young people wanting to
join those organizations and continuing
to get on with the job of running the
country and and defending uh you know
defending democracy and freedom in a way
that in europe we haven't seen for
decades by supporting the extraordinary
ukrainian uh leadership of uh president
zielenski and his amazing people who are
talking about local political russian
events yeah we're talking about domestic
politics if i may uh let me ask you
about uh
kierstama and beer with kia that seems
to be uh getting a pace
four of your colleagues i think i'm
right in saying four of your colleagues
in some form um
oliver dowd and nadine doris grant chaps
and also the defense secretary all
calling for a further police
investigation into what happened in
durham is that something that you would
uh lend your support to this morning so
across the piece if there were uh
concerns raised by uh you know
local people on the questions uh of of
lockdown rules then i would hope the
local police had uh investigated richard
holden uh one of the durham mps raised
this because he felt that uh durham
constabulary hadn't investigated it i
understand that there is some work on
going and i would absolutely uh
encourage them to look at it because uh
that's the point we did an extraordinary
thing through covid in terms of the the
the whole of our population genuinely
trying to do their bit and do their best
and i think should further investigate
well as i say i think uh
you should uh look at that look at the
situation and look at it properly in the
same way
well i don't know but uh it appears uh
not so uh or indeed whether you know the
uh reasoning that they brought forward
now that there seems to be more uh
photographic evidence is one they want
to look at again i would encourage them
to do that because i think that gives
competence to the police we police by
consent in the uk it's an extraordinary
thing we are incredibly lucky
and we need to make sure that we
maintain uh the trust and respect of our
police because uh they do the right
thing so i hope that they will look at
all that's been brought to them and
reach a condition accordingly can it be
in any way compared to what's happened
in dining street though i mean more
crime committed in downing street given
how many fixed penalty notices have been
uh issued than any other street in
england
so as i say i want would want all uh
police constabularies to look at
anything that's brought to them if they
are concerned and they look uh you know
back against legislation that was
brought in temporarily
and for conclusions to reach as indeed
the metropolitan police have uh in
london
and they have reached their conclusions
so do you think given that durham police
also of course were supposed to be
investigating what happened with dominic
cummings back in april of 2020 should
they look again at that well so again if
more evidence was brought to them than
they should if they felt they have
everything and they you know reach the
judgment accordingly then uh because
they did acknowledge that they've they
took his witness statement as what he
said in the downing street garden and he
has subsequently said that he was a
little bit economical with the actuality
when that
came about he was under pressure and he
did he's changed his story somewhat
since so you know there is more evidence
now so as i say i think as we police by
consent in in the uk that uh we want our
police forces uh to uh do what they need
to do with the evidence that's brought
to them so uh you know i hope darren
considerably will do that um as things
stand today do you think that this is a
resigning matter for sakia stamina given
that she was at an event that uh broke
the rules
as i say i'd like uh donald trump
to look at everything and to if they
felt a fixed penalty notice was uh the
appropriate uh you know uh
statement of of conclusion of it in the
same way the metropolitan police have
here for a number of people who were in
uh downing street at events that have
been deemed unsuitable uh then uh what
what i would want to see is is that same
fixed penalty notice i don't think those
are resigning matters uh for anybody i i
hear you but labour came out swinging of
course as we know this was angela reyna
if the chancellor gets a fine does he
have to go as well well i would say so
yeah anyone that's in the government
that decides to break the road pretty
empty front bench at this rate well then
there's plenty other mps out there
what do you think
she's saying that the prime minister and
also rishi sunak had to resign and they
should resign and she can't believe that
they're still in post and as far as
rishi sunak is concerned he says all he
did was he was going to a meeting anyway
and he just got caught up in it he's
taken his medicine and god is fine
what i'm saying to you is that as far as
um we don't know with miss rainer we
need to investigate that further but as
far as tequila is concerned he was at an
event indoors that was breaking the
knockdown rules at the time
so as i say uh i think the police should
now with all the
new evidence to come forward look at it
again and if they consider a fixed
penalty notice uh should be issued uh
then clearly that would be uh the tool
available to them to do so uh i don't
think that is i don't think i don't
think that's a resigning matter
personally what if you get a fixed
penalty notice okay so secure stamp is
the safest houses then
what's the fuss about then well it's
it's a the whole point is about uh the
demonstration uh of uh leadership i
think i wish you next point is a very
important one which is um you know if
the metropolitan police have determined
that that crossover through a door uh
was it was a point of was a point of uh
failure that's the right description uh
then uh they have issued their notice
accordingly and i understand that he has
you know paid it
and you know the matter is closed as far
as he is concerned but uh in the same
way uh that would be a reason for the
police to follow through and to reach a
conclusion uh and then uh for the you
know
uh everyone to be able to uh to to to
move forwards i think i mean the prime
minister has been clear so many times
it's a bit of mudslinging as far as
security is concerned and you know you
don't think you're not calling for him
to resign even if he does get a fixed
penalty notice so why are we bothering
well no i think what we all want to see
as i say we police by consent in this
country so if uh there is evidence
brought to the police which uh makes
them need to investigate whether or not
uh those uh covert rules were broken
they should do so and uh she still
shouldn't respond if you did well i
think the situation is too is to clear
the situation up and then move forwards
what uh kia chooses to do of course uh
as a result of any uh outcome such as
that would be for him to determine great
to talk to you thanks very much
individual pleasure i always appreciate
it thank you let's have a look at what
the papers are saying this morning the
telegraph leads with boris johnson's
address to the ukrainian uh parliament
today the prime minister will announce a
new 300 million package of military aid
the guardian reports the home secretary
pretty patel is to be sued
by ukrainian refugees who claim they
were left vulnerable to russian attacks
when their visas uh to the uk were
delayed
the times says rising inflation is set
to cost people on final salary pensions
about seven thousand pounds a year
because their income isn't fully linked
to the cost of living index
the mirror says the man regarded as the
main suspect in the disappearance of
madeleine mccann is to be denied parole
for an unrelated crime
under some reports that a man
masquerading as a priest managed to stay
overnight in the barracks next to
windsor castle
and a reminder that in just under a
fortnight we'll be taking the show on
the road for a special series of
programs uh going back to my roots and
finding out how the good people of wigan
feel about the cost of living crisis do
let me know if you'd like to get
involved by sending me a tweet using the
hashtag
k burley
boris johnson will become the first
world leader to address ukraine's
parliament since the russian invasion
later on today the prime minister will
tell ukrainians in a video address that
their resistance is their country's
finest hour bruce johnson will announce
a new 300 million package of support for
the ukrainian military today a convoy of
evacuees from mariopol has yet to reach
the ukrainian hell city of zapparizia
and further efforts to bring people to
safety have been hampered by the
resumption of russian talks the
ukrainian president has criticized
russian foreign minister sergey lavrov's
suggestion that adolf hitler had jewish
origins and said russia had failed to
learn some key lessons from the last
world war
our security and defence editor debra
haynes is in kiev for us this morning hi
deborah a very good morning to you um so
the british prime minister addressing
the ukrainian parliament
yes and he'll be evoking the
spirit of winston churchill in much the
same way as president zielenski did when
he addressed the british parliament um
in march uh boris johnson will be
talking about how in 1940 um in the
british regarded their fight against the
nazis as their finest hour and saying
that the fight right now that ukraine is
experiencing is this country's finest
hour a moment that generations will
remember as ukrainian armed forces
resist this russian invasion and also
coming uh he'll be speaking by video
link but with um the promise of more
military aid 300 million pounds worth of
military equipment including night
vision goggles jamming devices
and other uh equipment that is
absolutely fundamental in this fight
ukraine is facing um increasing
bombardments along the east of the
country and yesterday a senior u.s
official warned that russia might be
preparing to hold phony referenda
across the east in donetsk luhans
regions um trying to annex those
countries those parts of this country in
the same way as they annex crimea okay
for now thank you
still to come on the programme for you
this tuesday morning after 7 30 is the
evacuation of mario paul's stalls we'll
speak to former nato adviser and expert
on russia that's mark budger
we'll get the thoughts of prominent
human rights barrister adam wagner on a
gathering last year work here starmer
was caught on camera drinking beer when
coronavirus restrictions were enforced
i will also speak to the who's special
envoy for covid19 dr navy navarro on why
the pandemic has contributed to a global
surge in measles cases
the ministry of defense is investigating
how an intruder pretending to be a
priest reportedly spent the night in the
barracks with royal guardsmen close to
windsor castle what on earth was
happening there let's find out should we
shaman standing by for us at windsor
this morning um hi good morning what
happened
good morning it's quite bizarre isn't it
well for context victoria barracks is
home to the cold stream guards they're
the ones that wear the red jackets and
those bare skinned hats and they have
ceremonial duties as protectors of
windsor and buckingham palace well the
sun newspaper reports that last week
whilst the queen was at sandringham for
easter an unknown man appeared at the
gates here at victoria barracks and
claimed to be father cruz a priest and
said that he was mates with the
battalions uh with the battalion's
chaplain now despite the very bizarre
claims he was actually invited in and
later on end up drinking with offices
where he shared yet more stories now he
said that he trained as a ejector seat
pilot and had also served in iraq and
despite more bizarre claims he was
invited to spend the night and it was
only the next morning after he had
breakfast that suspicions were raised
and the police were called when thames
valley police arrived here they escorted
the man off the premises but says that
no further action was taken which could
suggest that the man had mental health
issues but despite that it is a huge
security breach and the army have said
that they have launched an investigation
they also published a statement which
says that the army takes the breach of
security extremely seriously and it will
be launching an investigation as a
matter of priority okay for now shaman
thank you
now 15 years on from madeleine mccann's
disappearance her parents kate and jerry
mccann have said their need for answers
for the truth remains essential the
mccanns have issued a statement to mark
the 15 years since their daughter's
disappearance it comes after the latest
suspect in the case christian bee claims
he was miles from the scene where she
disappeared
in the statement mccann said this
it feels no harder than any other year
but no easier either
it's a very long time many people talk
about the need for closure it's always
felt a strange term regardless of
outcome madeleine will always be our
daughter and a truly horrific crime has
been committed these things will remain
it is true though that uncertainty
creates weakness knowledge and certainty
gives strength and for this reason our
need for answers for the truth is
essential
martin brunt is standing by for is in
pharaoh in the capital of southern
portugal's algarve region this morning
hi martin um good to see you i recognize
that church behind you of course we saw
the mccanns attending that church very
often when they were in the early days
of the search for their daughter
yes it was a great
source of comfort to them we don't
expect to see them here
around the anniversary i mean i think
they are
they've taken a decision many years ago
that
they really didn't want to
be seen out and about in front of tv
cameras they're very private people
and they mark the anniversary in their
own way with that statement
on their website the fine madeline
website and also a reference a rather
moving reference to the winnie the pooh
stories uh an illustration of pooh
talking to his friend piglet saying but
the most important thing is even if
we're apart
i'll always be with you um now the story
that uh i've been working on is about
christian be the suspect uh in prison in
germany for a rape but suspected of
being madeline's abductor and he has
claimed that he has an alibi for the
night madeleine disappeared she vanished
between 9 and 10 p.m
from the holiday apartment half a mile
away from here but he says
by that time by 10 pm he was many miles
along the coast having sex with a young
german woman he'd met she was a
holidaymaker
and the next day he drove her to the
airport they were stopped by police
they were photographed she went to the
airport at the airport she was arrested
because she was carrying a pepper spray
and most of that he insists is checkable
he believes there would be records of
them being stopped the next day there'll
be a record of this young woman being
arrested
at the airport and if they can't prove
they were together at exactly the time
madeleine vanished at least
a lot of what he's saying will establish
that he did have a relationship with
this woman okay martin for now thank
you looking at some of today's other
headlines for you now and the premier of
the british virgin islands has demanded
his immediate release from u.s custody
arguing he is immune from prosecution
andrew fahey was arrested in miami last
week on cocaine smuggling charges
following a sting by undercover u.s
agents
[Music]
andrew lloyd webber's theater group has
faced criticism after it was announced
that the west end production of the
musical cinderella is to close with some
current and future cast members
suggesting they were only told when the
news was made public the production will
close in the west end next month less
than a year after its premiere
in the latest revelations in the johnny
depp and amber heard defamation case in
fairfax virginia the court listened to
witnesses of violence between both
parties the actor is suing his ex-wife
for 50 million dollars over a domestic
abuse article she wrote in the
washington post she is counter-suing for
a hundred million dollars here's katie
spencer
off the back of johnny depp giving his
take on their tumultuous marriage this
week we'll see amber heard take her turn
but before that the court heard from a
security guard of depths who'd witnessed
one particularly volatile late night row
which he tried to break up in march
2015.
i stepped
in between misheard and mr depp
at that point
out of the corner of my eye i saw a
fist
and an arm come
across my right shoulder and uh
i heard and saw a
closed fist um contact
mr depp and the left side of his face
that was misheard's fifth the initial
look on his face um
kind of mirrored mine uh kind of a look
of shock like
what just happened where'd that come
from
in a recorded deposition a nurse hired
to help herd with emotional and anxiety
issues was asked to talk through her
case notes including a visit she made to
deliver medication to the actress in
december 2015.
client had visible bright red blood
appearing at center of lower lip clients
stated it was from
injuries sustained in the
and then it's
like you see that from depp's talent
manager came an explanation of the
financial fallout the actor experienced
after heard's washington post piece was
published with respect to johnny it was
it was
catastrophic because it was coming from
you know a first person account it was
not from a journalist with depth
witnesses now drawing to a close having
listened as her character was pulled
apart by his experts in the coming days
heard will now get to have her say katy
spencer sky news
it's that time again and another iconic
night at the met gala with celebrities
showcasing the best work of top fashion
designers one a-lister made head's turn
with a particularly special number you
may remember who wore it first
happy birthday
to you
happy birthday
to you
[Music]
happy birthday
mr president
happy birthday to you now here she is
kim kardashian wearing the marilyn
monroe dress that she wore when she
famously sang happy birthday to the us
president in
1962 jfk of course kimmy kay seemed to
find it just as hard to walk in the
dress as monroe did looks amazing
doesn't it
uh the world's richest man elon musk
strikes a struck a pose on the met
gallery carpet with his model mother
mae
there you go
and other outfits fashion's biggest
night delivered a ton of surprises
including twinning looks and actress
blake lively's owed
to new york with a twist
i always wonder what happens if they
need to go to the loo
quick look at the weather
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
fairly cloudy today with a scattering of
showers and some more general patchy
rain for the northwest later on mostly
mild but rather gray now with some
patchy fog and a little rain in places
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
and some of the best pictures that we've
found in the papers for you this morning
lily's put these together for you today
a mixture of emotions from these young
ladies as they enjoy a day out at a fun
fair in small heath park in
birmingham following
two years of pandemic restrictions
thousands of people were able to gather
right across the country for eid
let's have a look at the telegraph
should we uh what a way to burst onto
the scene this is the moment 25 year old
ellis cross an unknown club runner from
south london beat samo farah to win the
10 000 metre vitality london race ellis
who works at a running shop paid 37
pounds to enter the race
after organizers didn't award him a
place in the elite
field
huh
that'll teach him and this one here we
go from uh how to enjoy a bank holiday
monday looks so much fun doesn't it
competitors took to the water in
hovercrafts at the alliton park in north
yorkshire to see who would be crowned
champion in the first race of the season
i'd love to do that looks fantastic
now let's uh update you on our top story
here on the breakfast show on sky news
this morning the big breaking news from
overnight on u.s abortion laws a short
while ago the international trade
secretary anne marie trevelyan told me
she was concerned about a potential plan
to overturn a historic law that
legalized abortion
it's sort of part of part of our history
that
that acceptance that actually women
should
have control of their bodies was
something that set a standard for the
rest of the world issues of concern are
always raised to diplomatic channels
whatever they might be they're done
privately often because that can be a
most effective way
of you know setting out the view but
this is a matter of concern i it's what
i'm trying well i think it's a matter of
of great concern i think to to all women
uh in the us if this is a rowing back on
a you know 50-year
50-year state of state of of things
tomorrow is here thoughts tomorrow good
morning morning k well it's fascinating
that anne marie trevallion in response
to this huge story that's come out of
the u.s with this draft ruling leaked
from the supreme court i think that's
the first time that has ever happened
suggesting they might overturn
abortion laws is saying that if that
were to happen and we won't find that
out for a couple of months the final
ruling that it might be raised through
diplomatic channels because of course
ordinarily although the us has a very
different approach to abortion than we
do in the uk that is not generally
something that prime ministers or
ministers
weighed into publicly i remember even
when this issue came up in northern
ireland three or four years ago theresa
may as prime minister who said that she
supported the current abortion laws said
that it was for northern ireland
politicians to to choose the way forward
so um even in other parts of the uk it's
not something that prime ministers tend
to to wade into but anne-marie chevalien
is suggesting it's so serious that we
might do so of course and very important
uh one to watch both implications for
the supreme court and for for women in
america i thought it was interesting
what she was saying as far as beer with
kier was concerned as well she felt that
even if he did get a fixed penalty
notice that's somewhere down the track
if ever and she thinks he should still
remain in post well of course very
difficult for cabinet ministers to
suggest that a fixed penalty notice is a
resigning matter since the prime
minister has already got one and may
well get others in the coming
weeks and months yes i think this beer
gate issue is becoming a growing problem
some of the unanswered questions labor
say of course the prime minister has
broken the law he has received a fixed
penalty notice paid it and apologized
for it kierstama has not broken the law
and therein is the huge difference but i
think there are some inconsistencies
emerging in accounts of what went on and
that night in april 2021 in durham uh
which some in some newspapers are
particularly highlighting and sakistam
is continuing to get questions about it
i think we've got a number of
conservative cabinet ministers now
saying that durham police should at
least investigate uh what went on even
if there weren't any breaches of the
rules okay we'll see you for tomorrow's
take out nicely then look forward to it
thank you very much indeed well uh let's
get more on the situation in ukraine now
joining us once again on the program is
mark voyager he's a former special
adviser to the u.s army in europe hello
thank you so much for taking the time to
join us on the programme this morning uh
we know that the british prime minister
will be speaking to the ukrainian
addressing the ukrainian parliament
later on today how important is it do
you think for ukraine to see this
worldwide support
good morning kay and thank you for
having me again it's absolutely
important and critical for ukraine to
see
this massive international support
being demonstrated in this in these
difficult times uh obviously uh we've
already had uh multiple uh high-level
visits including that of the u.n uh
general secretary
but also from the european um
union uh union's leadership uh the u.s
two u.s secretaries the state and
defense um so this is a clear sign to
kiev uh not only to the government of
course but the the ukrainian people that
the west has not
uh he is supporting them to the end that
the west is is ready to
uh do what's necessary to help them uh
achieve victory you know uh your own uh
secretary of uh defense has stated
clearly that victory uh means the
liberation of all the occupied
territories of ukraine and the um
reestablishment of ukrainian sovereignty
so in that regard all these visits are
of critical importance for ukraine
yeah so many famous ones that i can't
remember off the top of my head uh speak
softly but carry a big stick and the
ukrainians want that big stick in the
form of heavy artillery and other
military weapons that's what they need
isn't it
absolutely teddy roosevelt over 100
years ago the american president you
know said that and this uh saying hasn't
lost its uh
its importance and yes the ukrainians
who in the beginning
started with uh receiving from you know
mainly light uh weapon systems uh
anti-armor etc now are getting
uh you know really something that they
probably haven't even dreamt of i mean
we you know we're already talking about
uh heavy artillery
especially long-range artillery which
would allow them to penetrate deep into
the russian occupied territories and
destroy russian forces there um also
as far as i know ukrainian pilots are
already training on f-16s and other
western airplanes as as a whole it's a
revolutionary step because ukraine is
already talking about moving uh from
soviet the old soviet uh russian-made
weapons and standards to nato ones so
yeah you know come come the time to to
to accept ukraine to nato several years
down the road or copel even earlier they
will already uh be familiar with with
the nato weapons and they'll be
you know already prepared to um
to use it and integrate within their own
uh
forces
excellent knowledge on roosevelt you can
be on my quiz team anytime you like
we're hearing uh the finnish newspaper
is reporting that finland will apply for
membership um
to nato uh in just a week or so time
potentially sweden could then follow
after that if this does continue to
happen how volatile do you think that
could make the region given what we've
heard from russia
volatile regions are only those that are
not members of nato you know the history
of those conflicts shows that russia
attacks effectively non-nato member
studies georgia
moldova ukraine it hasn't there to touch
any any inch of nato territory yet and
the baltic states
finland and sweden as you said have seen
that
and
i must say vladimir putin with his
arrogance aggressive policies in the
region has achieved
miracles really of
convincing even the swedes to forego
their
300 plus years of neutrality
so i expect them to get tracked into
nato this is a a
historical chance for them
instead of waiting for several years as
is the tradition in such cases
and ultimately this will strengthen uh
tremendously the nato eastern flank
because now we'll have a continuous
contiguous effectively border
nato border from the arctic's ocean down
to
the black sea
and the caucasus this is of extreme
importance in the uh global efforts in
containing putin's russia
i wonder if you had a thought also um if
i may ask you about the fact that uh uk
estonia i think denmark um they're
france as well i think they're all
carrying out battle drills um in estonia
are very close to ukraine of course um
is that saber-rattling or is that
potentially preparing for a greater
involvement in your opinion in what's
happening in ukraine
well these are definitely uh these are
logical uh efforts uh in containing
russian showing the the dictator in the
kremlin
that uh again he shouldn't uh even there
touch any any inch of nato territories
as president biden stated so i wouldn't
make any dramatic claims about that but
definitely uh you know
potential potentially aggressive russian
moves especially down into moldova and
other areas
uh you know are being contemplated and
therefore such uh exercises are
extremely important in keeping the
readiness the interoperability um and
integration of the nato forces and again
they send a very strong message to
moscow don't dare
touch nato territory uh you know what
else will happen we'll see but putin has
again achieved the impossible he has
actually consolidated nato and brought
more nato to his to russia's borders as
opposed to less as was his
original intention so he's lost even uh
on that strategic account which is a
great victory for for the west and for
ukraine of course
and in return we are hearing from let me
just check the name dmitry kesley off
who is a tv host apparently very
pro-putin in russia claiming that
president putin has placed the country's
nuclear forces on combat alert how
should the west react to that
well this is the uh yet another attempt
by the kremlin
by
the kremlin regime to actually uh try to
intimidate the west
uh now that they have failed miserably
uh you know their armed forces in
ukraine are bogged down so at the
tactical operational level they're
they're losing the war and the only
thing that they can show for
to the russian people and to the world
are their nuclear forces
again i don't think putin is ready to
start a global nuclear war that would
mean the end of his regime
and his most important goal of you know
after the re-establishment of the you
know eurasian
kind of conquest you know around russia
is actually to keep the regime within
russia intact and turn it into a new
soviet uh system of source so if a
global war occurs
obviously this dream will collapse will
evaporate so i don't think he'll start a
global war unfortunately he may be
attempting to use maybe tactical nukes
at some point
in the theater of operations uh if he
believes he's he's losing the war
completely
uh therefore messages uh by the u.s
leadership and by nato are absolutely
important to to
deter him from from even dreaming of
using wmd on
european soil
okay good to talk to you as always
thanks very much indeed for your
expertise it's always appreciated
thank you thank you
just want to bring you some heartwarming
news uh from ukraine despite the news
that several hundred people are still uh
trapped in mario poll have a look at
this
a ukrainian nurse who lost her legs
in a land mine
explosion has shared an emotional first
dance with her husband after getting
married
in hospital
how can you watch that and not be
tearful
23 year old oksana and her groom victor
were walking home one evening in march
when a landmine exploded beneath oxana's
feet she lost both her legs and four
fingers but after a series of operations
her wounds have begun to heal after the
accident the couple decided that there's
no time like the president and tied the
knot on the ward of oxana's surgery
center
secure stoma has accused conservative
mps of mudslinging over footage of him
drinking a beer with colleagues at a
time when coveted restrictions were in
place
human rights lawyer adam wagner says the
labour leader didn't break the rules um
hi adam thanks for joining us why do you
think he didn't break the rules
well i i've never thought this was
particularly convincing as a as a
rule-breaking event because
labour said originally this was um on
the 30th of april last year it was
during the just before the build up to
the local elections it was in a
constituency office it was about 10
o'clock at night and the labour party
said
they ordered food for people um to feed
them because there wasn't anywhere else
open to get food
and if that that as a reason um given
that the um given that the rules allowed
you to have a gathering indoors which
was reasonably necessary for work
um then i i don't see how the police
could take it any further because
they've been given what sounds like a
reasonably necessary for work um
excuse me
could the pm say the same about uh the
meeting in in the cabinet room
well no because the meeting in the
camera if you're talking about the
birthday party um
that the purpose of that gathering
wasn't to feed colleagues or to do
anything for work purposes it was for a
birthday party which wasn't allowed and
i think the difference is look i mean
there's obviously everybody um
everybody in the rules was treated the
same whether the the police action um is
the same as is a different question
but i i the difference with the
government gatherings i think is that
the government as far as i know in
relation to those 12 gatherings has
never given a an excuse they've never
explained why
any of those gatherings were reasonably
necessary for work i think it's only the
media
um and individuals who have sort of done
that work for them but as far as i know
the prime minister has never said look
this is why the gathering was reasonably
necessary for work all he said is i i
didn't realize it was um a break of
breaching the rules um you know it
wasn't obvious at the time
so i think that's the difference from
the police perspective once the the
labour party is saying kirsten was
saying
this is the purpose of the gathering we
couldn't um feed everybody unless we we
you know ordered in food and briefly
stopped work at 10 o'clock at night just
before the local elections once he said
that it's difficult for the police to
say oh actually we we believe it wasn't
necessary for work
um unless they can find some um reason
why why what he's saying is wrong or
false
does it hinge his defense on him having
they having gone back to work after
they've eaten
no no it doesn't um because they i mean
that wasn't the original reason the
reason was i know he said and we went
back to work but that wouldn't make a
difference the question is
was it reasonable for them on that
evening
10 o'clock at night to order in food to
to feed people who were working together
for the
constituency from the local constituency
office for the elections and if the
answers i i think the answer look i mean
the rules aren't completely clear the
rules don't say you can or cannot have a
gathering to feed people before uh
local elections
but from the police perspective they've
got to reasonably believe that there is
an offence committed and i just don't
see how they could take it forward once
the um once a reason like that has been
given
i'm sure you always say to the people
that you represent be honest and open
straight from the uh get go
and the fact that we know now that
angela rayna was there in some form not
sure what time but we were told for some
time that she wasn't um that is why
um more and more questions are being
asked isn't it
yeah i mean i can see that from the um
from the media perspective that the fact
that [ __ ] that they originally said
something which wasn't true that she
wasn't there um would
get people to say well what else don't
we know and that's fair enough um it
just doesn't make any difference
for i i don't understand how it makes a
difference from to having a reasonable
excuse who was there i mean if there
were but i suppose that if there were
people there who had nothing to do
with the local elections such as the
birthday gathering the the decorator and
um boris johnson's wife were there i
think that does make a difference
because it does suggest the gathering
isn't work related or isn't related in
the way that they said but i'm not sure
how
the only way it calls things into
question is say well what else aren't
they telling us and you know that
you know that's up to other people to
figure out but i don't see how angela
rainer being there makes any difference
to the original reason given
it's good to talk to you thanks very
much indeed for your insight adam as
always appreciate it
now in other news measles cases have
surged worldwide this year amid
disruption caused by covid19 the un has
warned that the increase suggests
outbreaks of other diseases are likely
to be on the way who better to talk to
about this or let me show you a couple
of graphics 79 in the first
two months of the year compared to the
year before
as i was saying dr dave navarro is with
us now the whole special envoy for the
global covert 19 response and in
addition to that um obviously you've got
a view on what's happening as far as the
measles are concerned i know that you
have young people in the family don't
you how concerned should we be
well
you know modern life is about
using modern science
to keep ourselves healthy and safe and
vaccination against the common illnesses
of childhood is one of the absolute
basics of modern life
and we've got really good vaccination
programs all over europe to keep kids
safe one of them is the vaccination
program against measles but it's been
slowed down because kovid has really
taken up so much of health care and so
we've got an awful lot of people who've
missed out on measles vaccination 73
million throughout the world and that's
meant that this year in the first few
months they've been 17 000 cases of
measles globally whereas in the first
two months of the previous years it's
usually been lower 10 000 or less so yes
we've got a global
measles epidemic
and that worries us because
measles can be a very dangerous disease
we just got to get the vaccinations
working again and that's part of getting
health services working again as covid
settles into a more regular position in
our lives okay so what do we need to do
as parents grandparents to try to
protect our kids apart from giving them
the inoculation
yeah i'm sorry about that yes well i
mean i think
it did we've learned a lot about keeping
ourselves and our kids safe and the
value of hygiene the value of actually
not going to nursery or to school if
you're sick if if you can be kept at
home all that does reduce infection and
then secondly of course i do want to
stress about immunization i know you
said it but a lot of folk have actually
thought to themselves well will all this
fuss and bother about covid perhaps we
won't take our kids to be immunized in
any way it's quite difficult because
doctor surgeries have been using a
different working arrangements so that
is my main request to everybody please
get your child vaccinated please talk to
the local nurse or doctor about
vaccination options it really matters
it's so so important and with measles
the more people who get vaccinated the
more likely we are to get that the whole
measles outbreaks under control
okay and just before i let you go what
else are we concerned about as far as
diseases viruses that um our kids might
catch and spread
well um thank you i mean
there have been reports of of other
conditions emerging liver conditions and
so on and what i've noticed is that most
of the worries are related to the fact
that our health services and our lives
have been so disrupted by kovid so my
basic point to everybody is as things
gets going again please get back into
the rhythm of getting regular checkups
for your child's health and for your own
health
if that can work because it really
matters that whole preventive health
care is key to our collective future and
i'm just going to say okay that covid
has not gone away so i am going to ask
everybody keep a lookout for if it comes
back again surging back into your
communities don't throw away those masks
get them out again and be ready to put
them on because kovid does have a habit
of coming back and masks and physical
distancing are really important
protectors
i'll let you go we've only got 30
seconds left on the show but how
be remiss of me not to ask about otto
okay my otto is fabulous up and walking
well and with his brother isaac he's
just absolutely one of the bright boys
of brill near aylesbury what a what what
a village and what a beautiful place i
hope they're having a sunny morning
i'm sure he is the brightest little boy
that anybody's ever seen in the whole
world that's right that's okay
it's good to talk to you as always
doctor thank you so much for joining us
on the program thank you
what on earth's happening in the u.s
stay tuned and find out
[Music]